-All right, everyone, it's time
for "Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing
every week
where I send out a hashtag,
and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
And since we're celebrating
"Nana" Week this week...
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I sent out the hashtag
"NanaQuotes,"
and I asked you to share
some of the funniest things
that your nanas have said.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
number-one trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
A lot of people have love
for the grandma, for the nana.
This first one's
from @brendanburkeNRT.
He says...
He's like, "No."
[ Applause ]
This one's from @annielynne2002.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, like,
"Hey, squeeze the bottle."
[ Chuckles ] That's a good line.
This one's from @H2Obirth.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Groovy music plays ]
This next one's
from @hammerheadhope.
[ Crowd chuckles ]
She says...
Yeah, that's how they cheat you
out of the water --
they put extra frozen water
in there.
This one's from @brittb412.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's funny.
-Oh, yeah.
-She would haunt them.
[ Laughs ]
Not hurt them,
she's gonna haunt them.
That's genius.
This one's from @mmiller215.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
It's a thinker.
-Yeah.
-It's really funny,
though, yeah.
How am I doing? Well,
let's just say this much --
I ain't buying
any green bananas,
you know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @Kevin44274458.
-What is it?
-He's like, "How come
no one's following me?"
Uh...
[ Laughter ]
I have no idea.
Maybe it's
his Social Security number?
I have no idea.
-Yeah.
-People don't care anymore.
-Bank number.
-People have gone a little mad.
-Yeah.
-He says...
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pecky. Oh, that's funny.
Sounds nothing like Pablo.
[ Laughs ]
"Oh, give it to Pecky
over there," like, what?
This last one from
@AKperezidents. They said...
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.